quickly outline our plan that's not good
and then we can maybe maybe you know
wait wait a couple moments for people to
show up in a full-strength
and then get started what do you think
about that yeah so what we're thinking
of doing is kind of dividing the session
which is gonna be two hours of storing
mented into two parts the first part
we're thinking of doing is Tory plays a
standard time control training game 15
plus 10 so you know serious allowing
time to concentrate and think we both
mute our mics to each other so neither
of us hears the other person and we both
commentate so Tory commentate says she's
playing I'm commentating on the game
observing pointing out good things bad
things kind of critiquing and then we
convened after the game is finished then
we both hear each other and we discuss
the game I point out my thoughts Tory
points up her thoughts and we do that
for two games that should take about an
hour give or take and then after that we
will transition to some opening study so
I'll be showing some openings talking
about some general principles and
hopefully we'll get some cool stuff
going there and that might take you know
again another hour give or take and were
more than down to somewhat improvised if
you know if the crowd desires something
something else or something's one
particularly well yeah
I'm hype - I'm really excited mm-hmm
hi Perpetua I know this it's really cool
yeah we're hoping that this will be the
beginning the humble beginnings of a of
a tradition yeah isn't as kind of
planned like last-minute like wasn't
like the last week I think so I think
there's more like next month or whatever
I think we'll have more exciting stuff
all right you know more clean-cut yeah
promotion stuff I guess
yeah I'm hoping you guys the layouts
okay how much I tried to fit in the
beautiful graphic and but if anything is
bothering bothering you let me know
I'll see what I can do yeah I did reach
1300 actually a couple weeks ago I did a
piecemeal summer series and I got paired
up with like 1600 I think it's so much
rating with a party of 146 Wow exciting
stream today thank you so much for aid
we are doing that last census the first
I was like a hopefully a good series by
Joe Brown but yep we were just kind of
talking about format and plan for today
yeah so those are we just trickling in
we'll start with we'll start with two
training games and Tory plays and I'll
be commentating on them and then we
convene up for the game and discuss it
in my experience I think that's it's
very interesting because it affords kind
of you the opportunity to play and to
have fun and we get kind of the best of
every world I think there's nothing like
you know I can talk about stuff but
playing is really the the meat of
training I think yeah I don't know how
much of my chess you've actually watch
before I stuff
you'll pay you well I watch your your
matching it's Magnus and I mean your win
against Fabiana on the US Championship a
couple months riveting but I was it's my
seat no but I am I
I've seen your games ago I saw that
smothered mate that nasty smother made
yeah there was a couple days ago maybe a
couple months ago a couple months ago I
don't think my parents think it's
actually not easy to do that I can
probably count on one finger in the
amount of some other mates I've
delivered in a real game even online hi
Omid but yeah whenever you want to start
the games or whatever oh yeah I'm
thinking we can uh what do you think I
think we can we can we can jump in yeah
so
so yeah just a reminder that we're gonna
mute each other's mic to each other so I
won't hear Tori Tori won't hear me and
you're welcome to watch both of us and
observe our own takes on the game that's
being played we are in squad stream two
so you can easily switch between streams
yeah it should be pretty close so are
you following me right now now I'm
following you okay I will start my game
now and I will mute myself likewise
alright so I just muted myself
that's the Tori story can't hear me uh
and Tori has started her game she's
playing white against mr. al-sheikh for
hoping that you guys can see everything
fine
Andy forty-five has been played curtis
mistake night of three okay so this is
of course standard night seasick let's
see what Tori what opening Tori chooses
I mean I think most people who are
starting to play usually play the
Italian which is kind of the rite of
passage opening but um you know right
Lopez scotch there's a lot of good
opening sartorius Tori's probably
thinking about which line to choose
she's playing perfectly so far basic
Knight c3 the four Knights also a
perfectly viable opening choice so this
is completely lost
Oh Bishop c5 so Tori can resigned here
she is she has already made three
mistakes out of three moves I have no
more interest in comment the rest is
easy just kidding so Bishop c5 is an
interesting I mean of course as you guys
probably know Knight f6 here is um is
the main move leading into the four
Knights what is the drawback of Bishop
c5 the drawback is that white now has
the move Knight takes e5 the point being
after Knight takes e5 there's d4 Tory
decides to play Bishop c4 which is also
of course completely fine
now Knight f6 transposes back
to the four Knights and we'll see
what-what el-sheikh plays I mean I have
six yeah that's kind of an old line
where both both sides develop
symmetrically and you know I can also
play some music by the way what's up
supper I don't know if people but this
is a more instructive stream so
hopefully you know you won't get bored
so in that Essex indeed has been played
what is the idea here for white now
white needs to complete is her
development as fast as possible and
there are two ways to the to do this she
can Castle or she can play d3 opening up
the bishop and develop the Bishop to g5
965 now does not work because after
Knight takes d5 the bishop on c4 will be
hanging does the four Knights usually
lead to a draw no I wouldn't say that
it's a Drudge opening necessarily there
are a couple of draw is in the four
Knights that I might show afterwards but
I wouldn't say that it is they did by
nature leads to draw position so Tori in
fact plays d3 she's playing perfectly so
far the opening stage
she's got down h6 what is the idea to
stop the Bishop whoa that's not the idea
to stop the bishop from developing to g5
very sensible move so where does this
Bishop go
the bishop goes usually to square III
here now you might be saying well what
does that do because blacks gonna double
the pawns by taking the bishop on the
other hand castle castle logical by
white gets the F file yeah file is very
important here what is White's plan here
normally it's to operate on the Kings
side and that's the point of Bishop III
there is an alternative plan which is to
play Bishop d2 queen c1 and try to
sacrifice on h6 but that is that is a
little bit artificial and black has a
lot of ways to stop that what else is
there I mean why can't play moves like
h3 but rook e1 Tory is played which I'm
not a big it's not a mistake but I'm not
a big fan of this move why because the
rook belongs on the F file as I
mentioned now the move this should be
three is not going to be as effective
now the problem is the rook looks good
here but in fact it kind of stares at
this pawn so if the e-file were open I
look at this move differently but as it
stands probably a little bit of an
inaccuracy ninety-four interesting so
what
the idea the e5 pawn is left hanging but
if Knight takes e5 what I think I'll
shake is preparing is d6
leading to a very quick development of
his pieces after Knight back to f3 in
Bishop g4 painting that night so Tori
has to be very careful here she has a
decision on our hands and pink spoofer
of course if I can remove the Bishop to
b6 e does not as a very good point it is
not have to take tortillas play-doh
should be through which I like a little
bit more it's a little safer than taking
the pawn so I like that decision what is
black want to do now probably d6 now
Knight takes e5 is a threat so you know
so I'm expecting d6 from black now black
isn't a bit of a pickle already because
if black plays d6 what can what can Tory
then do Tori can capture the night with
with her Bishop ruining the pawn
structure which is why our shaykh takes
the knight now the drawback of what he
just did is that is that he's moved his
knight one two three times in exchange
for a night that's only developed once
now Tory puts her queen on a very nice
square of three we're in fact guards
word in fact controls the FL now let's
see which what Tory recaptures with the
correct way would be to capture the pawn
as I previously mentioned that leaves
the f5 open and then she can relocate
her ripped out one and start pressuring
the F pile but one of the things that's
important to understand is Tory might be
paying attention to the fact that if she
takes on e3 with a pawn that doubles her
pawns but it's important to make the
judgement that that's less important now
than opening the F file so it would be
much less accurate to take on e3 with
another piece if she takes with the rook
that kind of lets block off the hook
like and then just complete heard about
his development with d6 the reason i'm
yuda tory is because she's commentating
on her end on her stream i'm
commentating on her game here i want to
let her concentrate and and find her own
moves after the game finishes we will
convene again and discuss the game she
decided to take with her queen so that's
one thing that we might discuss
afterward is it's very important to
understand that sometimes you do need to
violate positional principles that's the
sacrifice you need to make for tactical
reasons oftentimes so ru responds with a
three which again not a mistake but what
exactly is the point of this move she
potentially a square for her bishop on
82 but it's a little bit too slow I
would have considered playing f4 instead
again trying to open the F file black
responds with a6 potentially preparing a
queen side expansion of b5 so it's a
pretty quiet position there's not much
going on white really has two ideas here
one is to create play f4 as I like the
other is to prepare a central striker d4
so we'll see which of these which of
these Tory ends up choosing white can
also play a neutral move like h3 now
Tory's probably deciding on what plan
now this is a position where you need to
decide what plan to to choose because
there isn't enough naturally going on in
the position to dictate you know have
sequence of moves and oftentimes when
you're stuck and you don't know what
plans to choose and a story plays a four
which is interesting she stops b5 but
I'm not sure b5 was something that
necessarily needed stopping at the same
time I like this move but she has spent
a tempo playing a three and then eight
for maybe a four immediately would have
been a little bit more it would have
carried a little more pizzazz
so to speak but again you might be like
well she's made two moves at the same
point at the same time the position is
closed so you know it doesn't exactly
moves on exactly I don't know this is a
very dangerous moment
what does anybody see what black is
threatening here does anybody see what
black is threatening and I want to
include you guys because that's the
point of what we're doing here everybody
is hopefully benefitting what is black
threatening d5 followed by d4 d5 the
bishop has to move in d4 Forks the Queen
and the knight what this story have to
do she has to move one of the pieces
that are gonna be in the way either the
bishop has to move to a2 or b3 or the
Queen has to move from e3 a good move
here would be Queen g3 or Queen f3
especially stopping d5 entirely she
could also move the knight but it would
be a little bit passive I like the way
the knight is placed on c3 she could
also consider playing d4 blocking the
passage to deed for any one of these
things prevents d5 but especially when
you're only learning chess it's very
important to always start by asking
yourself what is my opponents threaten
to consider not only one move threats
but two and three move threats she
misses it which is which is a mistake so
route d1 is a clear mistake I think what
Torre noticed was that none of her
pieces are being attacked so she
proceeded with her idea and black in
fact plays d5 attacking the bishop now
it's a bit major danger zone the game is
not over why is the game not over
because a little Torre will lose a piece
here she can get a couple of pawns for
the piece she takes correctly now she
has to take on e5 she has to come to
terms with the fact that she's losing a
piece she can also play d4 here that
might actually allow her to save the
piece but that's a little bit
complicated t4 if he takes d4 then Queen
takes d4 pinning the Queen and if pawn
takes c4 than pawn takes a 5 opening up
the attack on the de Pombal Queen and
opening up the attack in the night so
that might be a very strong move she
could also simply take on e5 getting
coupons for the piece and getting an
initiative because the D file was open
so the game is far from over this is uh
it is only the beginning as Count Dooku
would say in Star Wars and that is a
very nerdy reference yes I'm owning it
yeah I admit and now we all saw that
says Aquila of course of course so Tori
I'm by the / thinking pattern in the
fact that her hands has reached her her
face area is signaling to me that she's
realized that u4 is coming now it's very
very important early chest psychology
when you blunder it's out it's very easy
to say it's hard to do you have to
recuperate immediately assume that it's
the start of a new game and you have to
find the lesser evil and I think that's
the key to to making a lot of comebacks
which I obviously do because I'm usually
in a loss position most of the time it's
very important to come to terms of the
fact that you made a mistake you
blundered now what can I do given the
situation that I have and so let's see
if Tory finds one of these options
either Queen takes e5 or Bishop takes d5
followed by Queen 65 that would be worse
can somebody explain to me conceptually
why would Bishop takes d5
what's up Michael Scott saw the news
we'll get to that later
why would it be worse to capture on g5
with the bishop then of the Queen on e5
could somebody explain to me
conceptually Judy will play one game and
you'll get to 2,200 you need a you need
to make peace with it
but we'll talk about it because then you
take with Queen well kind of but oh man
and Tory has found Z for it that is that
is amazing that is a serious serious
move I'm impressed I am legitimately
impressed because let us again reiterate
the idea if it takes d4 then Y can
actually take with either piece either
Queen takes d4 or rook takes d4 creating
a pin against blacks Queen which means
that the bishop on c4 is untouchable now
black is another move which is of course
to take the bishop immediately what is
white to them white captures on e5 of
the pawn noticed that opens up an attack
on the Queen and against tonight you can
follow along in your own board if you
want now that is not the end of the line
because after D takes e4 let me make
that move on the board D takes e4 D
takes e5 black can save the knight by
playing 97 defending the Queen and
removing the knight from attack but then
Y can advance the pawn to e6 she's got a
huge initiative because blacks pieces
are very passive that's what's important
to understand about sacrificing
sacrificing is very relative if you have
a huge initiative it shouldn't be afraid
of sacrifice pieces so this is a
fantastic move that and notice the Tory
did exactly what what she should have
done I just noticed that black does have
the move Knight g4 here which could be
quite nasty that could be a problem
because that removes the knight
preemptively from attack from an attack
square and it attacks the Queen forcing
Tori to move for Queen and then black
takes the bishop but that's not the end
because there that night on g4 could
later get into some trouble black ends
up taking on c4 immediately now Tori's
gonna take on e5 of the pawn
Tory's gonna take on e5 of the pawn
opening up the attack of the Queen and
the knight let's see if black finds 97
if he doesn't that white is clearly
better because notice that all of whites
pieces are positioned on open files on
very nice squares
if white ends up taking the night with a
pawn then Tory can then maneuver her
night around to d5 in to e7 or even to
b6 black is very underdeveloped like
those fine 97 which is not a tragedy now
after east 6 I like White's position
because all of her pieces are very
harmoniously placed but it's very
important to I've decisively here if
Tori kind of dilly-dally with a move
like Queens e4 then that could allow
black to consolidate that could allow
black to consolidate and as soon as
black consolidates that extra piece will
make its presence felt there are other
moves here like Queens e4 which would
also be fine even 95 so there's a lot of
most here that white can do to build up
her initiative but what would be an
example of a bad moves something like I
don't know Queen g3 or h3 the move that
white makes now has to be very targeted
toward developing the initiative if she
makes a move that you know that is a
little bit too slow then this is a
matter of one or two tempi I wouldn't
say that white is better objectively
speaking I would say that white is worse
if two computers were to play I would
bet that the evaluation is probably 0.7
maybe minus one in blacks favor but
known as minus one when you're down at
peaced is not a lot and that is the
mistake that a lot of beginners make I
think is that and not because they're
they're dumb or something I don't say
this because you know somebody is obtuse
you know it reminds me of Andy Dufresne
and Norton in the Shawshank Redemption
but you know people look at the
computers evaluation and they conclude
the objective the practical value of a
move based on the computers evaluation
but the computers evaluation tells very
small part of the story there are plenty
of positions which the computer or even
what even evaluate is winning which I
would still go for in a practical game
especially a blitz game where thinking
time is confined and a human is sitting
before you not a computer so you need to
judge a position based on the difficulty
of moves that one has to find we do go
over the game after Shawshank reduction
my favorite movie one of my 3 or 4
favorite movies I know that one by heart
Tory plays d6 beautiful she's playing
very
well but she's spent half of her time
it's only holding in 17 Mushu she'll
have to be a little bit careful black is
forced to take on e6 the moves rook e8
here would would also be possible but
that's just very scary after he takes up
7 forcing the King out so Tori is
playing extremely well extremely well
right now and let's see if she is
rewarded now what is the psychological
effect of the way that she's playing
when one side has the initiative the
other side has to constantly be
calculating constantly be thinking they
burn a lot of time they get fatigued and
that increases the chances of a blunder
even if they successfully deal with the
initiative at the start now I'll shake
is playing very fast so props to him
he's finding finding a sequence of good
moves opinions on No Country for Old Men
a movie that I also greatly like if the
rule that led you here if the rule you
followed led you here why follow the
rule that's I think the famous line I
don't know it exactly but I love No
Country for Old Men I've seen it a
couple of times I can make a logical
reference to Khan's hit the game like
I'm talking or its
ads or tails heads or tails just to save
your life decide now
tell no one my name is Anton Chigurh
I would like peanuts and fill up my gas
I'm invincible Oh what's up face just
this is untoned Shakur commentating on
Goldust tourist game heads or tails face
just know my place is waiting for check
checking the king and attack in the
Seaport pawn if the rule that brought
that you followed brought you to this of
what use of what use was the rule so she
checks on e4 perfectly sensible move I
would probably take on c4 immediately
leaving the King on h7 why because the
King on h7 can later be subject to the
fact there's a very famous nimzowitsch
quote could somebody tell me what it is
that applies perfectly to the situation
where you hold off on a particular move
what is the the cliche here that applies
nobody anybody anybody Bueller the alert
the threat is stronger than the
execution perfect espera wanna be so
sorry has taken on c4 white is doing
perfectly fine here now you might be
saying again she's down at PS what am I
even talking about am I like on the
drugs or something no because first of
all white is two pawns she has six pawns
white black has four hands all of whites
pieces are very nicely placed rooks on
an open fall Queen b6 very well played
black is playing well above his rating
as well this is a very nice move because
black is bringing the Queen out of the
pin and attacking the pawn enough to now
Tory has a difficult situation to
resolve I would play call an hits b2
actually didn't notice that thank you
for pointing that out extreme dota what
would I do I would play the move maybe
94 here the idea being we are defending
f2 and positioning preparing to position
the knight on g6 we have to play very
fast here these positions when you're
down a lot of material you cannot care
about pawns you have to care about them
you have to have your eyes on the prize
so 94 would be my one candidate move
another candidate move that I would
consider is something along the lines of
King h1 which could be calm which looks
slow but in reality you stop Queen takes
up to check on the other hand what is
black star black wants to move his
knight to f6
controlling the d5 score it's very
important to act fast that is why it
suggested 94 in the first place now
another idea which which looks very
brazen is to play 95 giving up the f2
pawn again I'm sure the computer will
refute this so don't check the computer
on this this is a purely practical move
the ITF 95 Queen takes f2 King h1 you
might be like well it's terrible to give
up the f2 pawn with check but if you
think a little bit further you might
notice that after that white threatens
rook F 1 so the the opening of the f1
might actually be in White's favor and
of course you get the Knight to d5 from
where it can later travel to e7 perhaps
even to g6 so you know you have to in
your mind be very disciplined about
understanding what type of positioning
do we have here is it a position where
you can afford to play slowly or is in
position where how to play fast would be
3 which Tory played it's a very
instructive mistake what was her idea
she was
at the b2 pond and and saying well let
me defend it first of all I can't take
on f2 but I wouldn't be worried about
that because again that opens the F file
and whites favor I would be a lot more
worried about a move like Knight f6 the
knight on f6 is going to fully restrict
white tonight and whites Knight is going
to be the sort of the screwdriver with
which you're going to open up all the
locks all the weaknesses and whites in
blacks position they can only be
accessed by whites Knight which is why
this temple is very important so after
Knight f6 I think white isn't a lot of
trouble while she still has two pawns
for the piece she no longer has that
initiative that we were speaking about
let's see what black can come up with
here by the way guys those of you just
joining us thank you so much for taking
time out of your day this is a
collaborative training session with gold
dust story the one and only
right now I'm commentating on her game
after she finishes we will reconvene and
discuss it together and then she will
play another one after that we will
transition to some opening studies so
black has taken on f2 which is a
double-edged sword as I mentioned the F
file opens in white in whites favour on
the other hand white only has one point
for the piece and we are squad streaming
as well I hope you're enjoying your meal
vlogs sorry I don't think it matters I
think this affords white torii a little
bit more time to think which is what we
want now black has to be careful because
rook f1 is the right black has to play
Knight f6 here I think closing off the F
file so in reality I think Queen takes
up two is fully justified here and only
if black finds the movement of six so
the game is far from over black does
find the move Knight f6 I think black is
playing nearly perfectly in this game so
you know Tori has played has played very
admirably but a credit to a Shakey's
found all the good defensive moves so
far now the game is never over and
that's my mentality is white is down a
piece she maybe no longer has the
initiative that she once did but how do
you make a comeback in chess how do you
come back from a completely lost
position which is a critical skill well
first of all you have to borrow Magnus
is quote one move at a time you cannot
think well I'm gonna win this game one
day because you can't imagine such a
scenario you're down a piece that just
depressed
further and makes you what you know not
more hopeful but less hopeful so you
have to pose problems to your opponent
one problem after another problem after
another problem no matter how small
these problems might seem if you pose
enough of them your opponent gets tired
he might lose his guard now Tory plays
94 which is a very interesting move that
I paid attention to earlier what is the
idea let's see if she can follow up
correctly after Knight takes e4 she
might be intending to move rook out one
painting the Queen on the rook and the
Queen has no retreat in order to keep
the rope guarded there is a flaw with
this and we'll discuss the flaw if black
does take on e4 but let's see what black
does here Alex files thank you so much
for subscribing with twitch Prime I
really appreciate it
hope you're enjoying the content thus
far thank you
now let me ask a calculation question to
you guys after and I would encourage you
if you have a board next to you follow
this on a real nice wooden board this is
I think the best way to learn after
Knight takes e4 rook up one where should
the Queen go black is a very strong
tactical response in that position black
does take on e4 with his knights after
rook f1 what is the correct move using
the fact that the King is located on h1
could somebody beautiful GM am sad after
rook f1 black chasm between c5 now you
might think well wait wait a minute wait
a minute
Queen takes e5 Knight takes e5 and again
the rook is hanging but this is where
the Italians have a word for this and
the Germans have a word for this what
are both of these words what is it that
black does after white captures on c5
and Tory takes on e4 correctly because
Queen rook F 1 Queen c5 would have been
losing either it is is not correct
extreme dota Intermezzo is absolutely
right that's the Italian word for it and
mission look very nice as the German
word for it it's an in-between move in
between moves in my experience are very
hard tactics to see a lot of people in
the club player rage especially in the
beginner range struggle with
intermediate moves because at that point
your brain you know it works more
automatically so it's very hard to alert
yourself to the presence of an
intermediate move Bishop f5 another very
good move like brings to this Knight is
Bishop out now leaving the b7 pawn
hanging and by in return the c2 pond
it's gonna be hanging these pawns are
all on light squares and anonymous gift
sir is gifting us up to neighbor boy
thank you so much miss your anonymous
gift her appreciate it
black is playing beautifully and using
his time exactly correctly so you know
you know we need to be clear about about
the fact that aureus is giving this game
her heart but the the initiative just
didn't quite work out now let's see if
she can put up a good resistance how
would I do that here you have to take on
b7 otherwise blacks gonna take on c2 for
free and she does now black has to take
on c2 with his bishop now after rooks t1
the problem is black has the move rocky
and black just has too much horse power
you know it's like white is driving
see blacks driving like a like I'm not
good with cars but some sort of like a
Corvette and and that's the problem with
extra material now a piece of advice for
you guys is basically when I was in my
mother's womb
if the classic advice you would get is
when you're up material you do what what
do you do when you're up material the
most cliched sentence of all time and I
for some reason I said that in a New
York accent or notor line just great
faces and you get some coffee so you
drink pieces when your material but what
is that a movie right for the Godfather
I guess but I think that's pardon my
french that's a load of malarkey in my
experience you sometimes you want to
trade your pieces but very often it is
precisely because you are off material
that an attack will work out better and
so you should attack when you're up
material and you shouldn't trade pieces
that's a very limiting mentality a lot
of people get in a lot of trouble
because when they're as soon as they're
up a knight or a bishop they set it to
be their life's goal to trade off all
all the rest of the pieces and and that
way they they they allow blunders into
their life and very often if you just
set your mind on attacking as black can
do with a mover of BA the point of that
move is not to trade off the rooks it's
to prepare the move Bishop e4 which will
forth the Queen and the G to square so
my advice to you would be and I'm a very
concrete player I like to think on Crete
Lee in on a case by case basis rather
than in principles sometimes there is
room for trades very often you want to
be able to attack you have an acting
career waiting for you Suzy Fox who
knows it's entirely possible I would I
accept all invitations if Woody Allen is
in the chat or even Woody Harrelson or
you know I'll even settle for for Steven
Spielberg even though you know or god
forbid Martin Scorsese thank you Chris I
appreciate it
I'm on the I'm on the Leo DiCaprio you
know just a bunch of you know just
amateur hour I could do much better job
but more about that later
rook AEA played I think black is flying
on the level of a grandmaster I'm gonna
be honest with you guys black is playing
off grandmaster and Tory what to do now
Ettore has to resist with with her final
ounces of energy how could she do that
definitely taking mini 8 is not the way
because after rook takes the it rook
takes here black has two threats rookie
1 threatening made on the back rank in
Bishop before forking the Queen on the
pond on g2 black the White has to play
the move rook g1 what is the purpose the
purpose is to guard the g2 pawn again
when you're completely lost you don't
resign you don't give up hope you've got
to create as many problems for your
opponent as possible so you know so
you've got to be you got to be you know
you got to cling to the last the last
ounces of hope and there's just no other
way psychologically to come back from
completely lost situations I agree
statute unfortunately blacks position
basically plays itself it's hard to make
a mistake here it's not the sort of
situation where you can truly create
problems and rooked you one very nice
Tories showing signs of a fighter
fighting with your last balances of
strength and that's very important it
doesn't matter what your rating is
you've got to put yourself in a
psychological position where you can
improve and to do that you got to be
used to being in loss positions and
fighting I think black is playing
absolutely on the level of a grandmaster
so far what would I do here I'd probably
play rookie to piling up on the G to
pawn and this is what I mean when you're
up material this fish of white doesn't
have a counterpart so this bishop
belongs on e4 but playing Bishop b4
immediately allows Queen takes a6 and
the pressure on g2 is not quite enough
to force Chapman however if black
positions a monster on e2 and then plays
Bishop before this pawn is going to be
indefensible so let's see if black is
able to find the move rookie to here
boom pow pow boom pop hawk subscribing
with twitch Brian thank you so much for
the sub my man it means a lot to me love
the support early on guys
and yeah maybe this guys listening to me
maybe he's on my stream so Oh
see this sleeper should be four maybe I
should suggest a queen blunder like
Queen f3 which might actually be a good
move unfortunately that's the problem
with this position but maybe I should
deliberately suggest a blunder of some
sort now he does play Bishop before I'm
not sure what he is intending after
Queen takes a six so Tory just has to
grab grab grab the only way she can come
back from this issue she gains material
oh but unfortunately black-ass okay this
is very interesting after Queen takes a
six it's very close to checkmate after
the sacrifice on g2 but I'm not
calculating right now I'm not seeing
exactly the checkmate yet that King
Aegeus I'm calculating a long line but
Centauri absolutely snaps on a6 quickly
very nicely done okay now obviously
black is completely winning still and
and he can play a lot of moves you can
play rook up six intending to carry the
rook over to g6 and pile up on G on g2
what else can he do he can probably take
on g2 I would bet you he does take on g2
now I don't see it yet because rook
takes three to rook e1 check rook takes
d1 Queen takes two and follow along guys
rook g1 we need four check rook g2 now
why is Rho Chi Chuan not checkmate in
that position can somebody tell me could
somebody tell me why the end of that
line work f1 is not checkmate because
and you got a look at the whole board
and he goes for this let's see if he
sees it because the queen is on h6
guardian upon another corner guarding
the square enough one a huge source of
blunders and I'm not saying this to dumb
it down i blundered for this reason is
precisely because you don't look at the
entire board your brain kind of sections
things off flanked by its length but I
do see a win here I can't believe Black
has found this so fast he's found it
faster than I have after rook takes c1
Queen takes you when rook g1 Queenie for
up G to black does have a win I believe
and what is that win it he does he has
not blundered this is actually correct
what is the win
mr. Davis good to see you now Queenie
one I'll guard I'll guard with rook g1
so that doesn't quite do the trick but
rook f2 says the Duke of France and
slowly down that's very nice rack up to
attacking g2 there's no way to defend
you - now I thought originally the
widest perpetual but after Queen taking
h7 white runs out of checks if white
guards the rook then with Queen h3 this
is a long line guys practice your
visualization what does black then do
what is black do after that no I don't
think he's watching the stream because
no this guy i I hate to sour the
atmosphere guys but this guy's played an
absolutely flawless game of chess
this guy's played a flawless game of
chess then woke up one checkmate because
now it's very important to realize this
small differences in the position when
you're calculating a long line one of
the biggest sources of mistakes is when
you assume that certain properties of
the position are the same as they always
were but that is not off now rook upon
us checkmate let's test if this guy is
actually watching the stream rock off
one mate and the game is over
rook f1 is checkmate
hahaha rook up one mate are a good game
and I have a story about my friend was
telling me about this how she many years
ago she had a game where her opponent
actually delivered not Tory but somebody
I know our opponent delivered made and
said Chuck made it was actually a
blunder of this exact Sorocaba played
very nice Queen see a track now White
has to stay in the game with Queen see
it in Queens g4 but unfortunately
there's just no way to stay about
checkmate and yeah it takes forever to
see him and one rook after two I don't
know what to tell you guys but mister
al-sheikh has played on the level of a
super GM in this game so you know but um
Queen ch-check Torrey hats off to her
she's not losing hope fighting into the
last drop of blood unfortunately if
there was a bishop say on a6 and why
would be winning so she's really
suffered because there's nothing to
guard the light squares other than the
Queen yeah other than the Queen there's
nothing to guard the light square this
guy is one every game he's played I'd
say basically and you know that's
interesting enough interesting enough
I'm gonna I'm going to he might be
underrated I hate to not someone to
throw it accusations and it might very
well be that this guy simply underrated
but I'm gonna ask the right thority to
to conduct a small investigation I'm
gonna ask the right authority to task to
to conduct an investigation hello and
let's see Tory will unmute herself
moments all right that would well I I
will tell you this my estimation of your
opponent's strength is probably GM level
yeah that's one thing they're playing
you know what what that implies I will
not say and I'm not implying anything
myself but you know well you know so
yeah the level of his play yeah he was
listening to me now it's funny because
at the very end I'll move 32 and shall
we make an analysis board to to look
over this game or we can both look at
our own boards and and follow along or
so what do you think I don't know it's
best my China's reporting 99.5% accuracy
and naturally I do that every time
actually that's that's pretty low what
do you say so that's I could do that in
my sleep casually ninety nine forty five
percent yeah I remember at oculus as I
remember being 99.5% of 1300 so Tori
you'll become a serious just where when
you do ninety nine point six percent
accuracy this is not serious I'm kidding
of course
so let's do um let me think if I click
on your game will you be able to
actually let's just let me open an
analysis board no no oh and I'll invite
you and then we can reconstruct the game
maybe okay so we do that through life
chest and then you click let me see
there's where is that feature that you
pointed out to create an analysis live
analysis
yeah we got a plane and click the point
well perfect it actually it actually
that game actually shows up now let me
invite you where is the invite feature
right I remember having the last time
using so Shane they say that was one of
my best games that was uh I was you
played you played your heart out and si+
invites there we go gold dust sorry ok
perfect you see the board yep fantastic
yeah I think I think Tori you found
every chance that you had to complicate
the position you found it literally
everyone so thing so the openings the
Bishop c5 to my knowledge so you played
the four Knights obviously Knight of 6
is the main move here and and I suppose
you were intending Bishop c4 that's
gonna transpose into the game that this
did transpose into the game actually but
Bishop c5 is a little bit non-standard
and what you can do here is you can
actually take on e5 yeah talking about
that on screen I've never actually like
remembered to do this ever in an actual
game people have done it to me before
yeah it's an annoying little idea
because um yeah Knight takes e5 d4 and
the point is not so much that you win a
pawn you don't want a pawn black as a
million ways to recover the pawn the
point is that you develop and you
control the center before your opponent
so Bishop d6 is standard here
sorry preparing to capture with a bishop
but now black has this awkward Bishop on
e5 he hasn't developed his King side and
you have a million moves here you can
just develop a Bishop t3 you can even
chase the bishop with that for and
control more of the center so I think
White has a bit of an initiative here
yes and my chat is confirming 99.5% yeah
so I've alerted mr. mr. FBI chairman and
CIA director you know to take time out
of there out of
days thanks Johnny DJ yeah the local
private investigators are on it they're
all on they're all in the case they're
unearthing the necessary photos but so
you played Bishop c4 which is fine
transposes and you've got this kind of
position castles castles this is all
logical I think this is kind of a first
instructive moment that I'd like to draw
your attention to okay you played the
move rookie one and I think it's very
important when you get it into a
position that you know you're not
exactly unless its theory then you begin
thinking concretely and the question
here is kind of what how are you gonna
put your pieces how are you gonna
develop and the move that occurred to me
is the move Bishop III and the idea of
this is that if Bishop takes it three up
takes a three on the one hand your pawns
are doubled right but what can you tell
me what you get in return what is the
benefit of doing this from a tactical
perspective what you get the file
precisely you've got the up file your
Bishop is already perfectly positioned
on c4 we're texturing the King and you
have a million maneuvers there to get
this attack rolling while black is busy
getting out of bed with d6 yeah you can
play 92 or 96 even because of the pin so
this would be kind of a more combative
move I think the problem with rook e1 is
if there was no pawn on e4 this would be
a perfectly sensible move but as it
stands while the rook kind of looks good
it's kind of standing staring at your
own pawn yeah so I felt like this was a
little bit too slow
he played 94 which is actually a very
advanced move did you see the
possibility of taking on e5 yeah I
usually what happens in this kind of
stuff is that I get really unsure about
myself and I'm really bad I'm a lot
better at calculating but I still like
struggle with what were your
considerations here well I I think I did
Bishop 283 I think it's what I actually
did but I did think about taking the
pawn so my free pawn
boom then I always want to make it
actually a free pie well it was not in
this case my dad is reporting that you
played nine 92.6% accurate so that is
amazing that would have probably beaten
like a combination of firoozeh Magnus
and Kasparov but this guy this guy was
wearing like four bulletproof vests but
so the problem with this
z6 and you have the right mentality of
you know what happens if is you know i'm
not trusting the fact that you can you
can make a move that just looks too good
to be true because often your opponent
has something under his sleep what you
also kind of have to balance that with
being able to call someone's fluff and
that I think comes with experience and
kind of tactical exercises now the
problem here is that your night is
attacked you can take enough seven and
this but this isn't great because he's
got two nice pieces for a rook and the
problem is if you move your knight back
to f3 then he has the nasty move Bishop
g4 pinion your knight and he's got a
huge attack for the pawn yep and so this
would be unpleasant so your decision is
absolutely correct then you took on e3
with a queen I thought that maybe taking
with the paw knows a little bit more
sensible opening up the F file again you
have really taken with a pawn like I
don't know why I think I got like
somebody maybe it's my chat or something
like a long time ago told me to like
basically not touched upon in front of
my king pretty much okay I did it I did
it for awhile but it always got me in
trouble
so now I just have never I've never
thought about taking mm-hmm yeah that's
interesting and that's correct if you're
thinking moves like cheap or but you got
a reason on a case-by-case basis is my
is my king in real danger if I move up
on here it is true that f2 is now an
empty square but black is not exactly
has not exactly masked as pieces on the
Kings side yeah there's not exactly like
military plans here if there was a
knight on g4 and a queen on h4 maybe we
do be having a different conversation
but it's I think in these cases you want
to think on a case-by-case basis my chat
is asking in the previous position had
you taken the pawn and played knight c6
which would be an interesting move I
think the reason here is still bitter to
you for and there's still a big a big
initiative after Queen d2 rook e8 this
Knight is actually quite awkward so I
think this still would have been bad for
you I think that's that's the response
that I have so you took with the Queen
which is fine and the critical moment in
the game a3 a4 was fine stopping b5 the
critical moment was really here I'm did
you miss the move t5 um I thought about
it but what did I play I knew you played
rook a d1
oh well okay star that was that was Tom
Ian but I didn't see what the actual
intent of it was which it's where I was
like oh sorry good I never like actually
like that's never happened to me before
so I was like oh
mm-hmm I mean rope t1 in the absence of
tactics that drew Bishop and maybe on a
2 this would be a great move because one
plan that I had my eye on was to open up
the center with t4 and notice that like
black is a little bit cramped so and
when your opponent is a little cramped
and your pieces are a little bit more
free I think it's a great idea to to
open up the center and you could have
done that I think immediately with a
motif or maybe this would have been a
little bit better
stopping the pawns progression so so in
terms of these sneaky moves I think
you're doing a great job of checking for
one move threats which there aren't in
this position but whenever your pieces
are kind of massed in the center that's
a precursor to a lot of Forks and double
attacks and you got to watch out for
those especially if the Queen and the
night are placed on a four Keable square
you got to envision the worst scenarios
take on the Russian pessimism and be
like what is the worst thing that could
happen in your nightmares you're gonna
see a pawn on c4 and then you got to
kind of look at the present position to
be like what could this actually happen
yeah so so after rook 81 I thought you
reacted brilliantly here with a move T
for which we were we were hoping you
would play and you did is very impressed
at a defensive resource and after he
takes the four Queen six before the
point is the queen is pin so she founds
this response which is by no means
trivial and then you followed up
correctly with these six so when you're
down material you want to open as many
files as possible you have to get the
initiative and you know the rest of the
game I just think he played perfect
moves so I was saying on my stream that
I think objectively black is much better
here if he's able to play perfectly
which is a tall order for any human
being but not for mr. al-shaikh for
who did that I think that may be your
final chance so to speak would have been
to take the pawn immediately you did
take the pawn after 24 now the point
here is is the King on h7 when you're
comparing looking on h7 and they came on
AJ what can you tell me about where the
King is better placed from a long term
point of view I mean I think a little
bit right now and why would that be they
can't check it precisely so you're when
you're when you're thinking about
complicated chess positions there's
almost two modes of thinking there's a
concrete mode which is what is he
threatening what is my immediate plan
and then there's the long-term thinking
of in the distant future in like 2026
when you know earth is blasted by meteor
or what will I be doing then and in that
case you can imagine a million scenarios
as you pointed out when you're checking
the king and that could be very useful
I'm seeing something where potentially
you could even deliver some sort of a
fork not here because there's Bishop f5
but it's very important to think about
that's what I call tactical awareness
about what could happen in the future
and that way you see a lot more tactics
than if you kind of look only the
immediacy yeah and after you gave a
check his King is relatively safe Queen
b6 was a brilliant move attacking both
pawns I thought maybe you could have put
put the knight on d5
it's Ryung trying to somehow muddy the
waters but none of this would have
really worked because something like
Knight f6 he trades off for a knight
it's just not enough horsepower here you
played b3 and after this I think the
rest of the game he conducted flawlessly
including this final combination which
was incredibly impressive I didn't see
this at first I thought that he would
play I thought that Bishop e4 was a
mistake but then we all realized
together that he had the sequence and
it's important that rook up one is a
mate here because Queen Queen guards the
square but he found rook out - and
unfortunately for you there just wasn't
any checks after Queen c8 King age 7
yeah I got I took a long time around
this point in a night yeah and I was
like I don't really know what yeah and
you were playing you like
mixture of God and like Superman
but I think that what are the lessons
from this game I think the critical
moment and I think that's how you want
to analyze their games is what was the
critical moment the critical moment was
definitely here um and what you can do
is is do more of the long-term thinking
even though you don't see a one move
threat which there isn't you've got to
be kind of a pessimist of the chessboard
and always ask yourself well what could
go wrong in the long term yeah if I had
my worst nightmare maybe the pawn would
land on T 4 and you're like wait a
minute that's pretty close to happening
but what could you have done here maybe
move the Queen f3
regarding the d5 when removing the Queen
from a 4/4 Keable square oh yeah does
that sound reasonable yeah and someone
to say maybe that's Penguin and I
enjoyed saying any sandbagging but even
for up for a G on this level of play
would be a tall order and after that I
think you reacted you reacted
brilliantly with the only exception that
maybe Queen 64 immediately would have
yielded more practical chances yeah
other than that I thought it was a nice
and clean game the one last thing I'll
say is remember when you're talking
about general chess principles try to
think on a case-by-case basis
think about the concrete situation does
Bishop e3 weaken my king even though I
move my pawn away from the Kings side in
this specific case the answer is no even
though in another situation with black
had more pieces on the Kings side maybe
the answer would have been yes okay so I
think those are the takeaways are you
down to play one more game or do you
would you like to switch to something
else what do you think sorry yeah I
could play another game that sounds
great and we'll do the same thing maybe
you'll be blocked this time yeah and
we'll do the same drill I think
hopefully you'll play it you'll play
someone who's from Planet Earth